this is the final uh
installment of chill chum for this
incarnation right and i have to say uh
we are back in studio now
we started in studio week one
and then we departed
and we went to the wilds of pasadena
suburbs yeah at night and we were in
your backyard
and it was a transformative experience
really how some transformers well for
the two of you because you got drunk
yeah yeah we did you both got did you
did you feel yourself getting a little
loopy here's the problem i'm normally a
lightweight so i would normally say yes
but i've had so much to drink since my
daughter was born that i just it's just
like water to me
now that's heartwarming
i mean worryingly so i'm asking for help
oh good
good can i tell you since your daughter
was born what's your routine do you have
a drink every night
no no longer but the first three months
i'm embarrassed to say i would have a
cocktail or three
a night you need to unwind it was like
i've never been like never before have i
been like that and i love her in this
did your wife say anything to you at one
point she was born
jesus
so you didn't get the i think you got to
cut back a little bit oh no she was like
no she's she's not the type well a lot
of
listeners have commented that throughout
the course
of chill chums in the wild in pasadena
um we were enjoying that lovely cocktail
you made yeah the chilled chum and
what's in the chilled jum well that's
another thing is people been asking the
the internet as the blogosphere
it's just been
i have to say
i i showed a lot of restraint i sipped
mine very slowly i didn't have too much
because i could tell that it was lethal
but it's delicious it is i will say this
it's fantastic it's a great drink thank
you here's what it is one and a half
ounce of makers mark bourbon
one ounce of palm pomegranate juice half
ounce of lemon juice bundaberg ginger
beer to taste as much as you want a
splash a little bit more but the ginger
is an ode to you hey that's nice and
then muddled strawberries for the chum
of the chilled chum and that's for one
cocktail so you can double or triple and
as i say muddled for your muddled mind
and muddled that's exactly right uh
logical
yeah that's what i thought the
connection was
the lemon juice the pomegranate juice
and the bourbon in a shaker with ice
pour it over rocks add as much ginger
beer as you like and muddled
strawberries
uh now
let's get to the more interesting thing
it's nice that you um have now broadcast
uh the uh
the recipe so that people can make this
for themselves
because it was extraordinarily uh tasty
drink but let's talk about when did you
know sona that you were going off the
rails a bit i think uh when everything
just seemed not that it's not funny
usually but when everything was funny
and then i was like i remember this
feeling i used to do this a lot your
foot was in the fire at one point
and you thought that was funny i
remember that you were giggling because
you saw the skin burning off and then
you saw a bone exposed and you thought
that was funny yeah i had my foot
amputated
and i'll post it of you leaning forward
holding your glass with two careful
hands right just like sipping it with
this sweetest grin on your face
you know what you were you were you were
gollum with the rings yeah i was
i had so much fun matt thanks for
hosting us that was just such a delight
and you know what i haven't i'm a
lightweight now because i don't do drink
but i take my edibles mostly that's my
release and that's a responsible message
yeah i've cut back on the drinking and
replace them with edibles edibles kids
yeah edibles get them at your local
dispensary yeah it's legal sure it's
okay yeah in california oh yeah yeah no
there's no judgment no there is judgment
no judgment at all you're judging
there's no judge reinhold just take it
easy do you hear that
i hear judge no no there's no judgment
that's just in your minds now he's
gaslighting yeah now he's like
pretending gaslighting judge i
had a very nice time i enjoyed it i
enjoyed it more than i thought i would
yeah and i'm just because i
no offense but it's hanging out with you
and your house
that was not an advertisement for good
times right no i seriously i thought you
were going to
i just didn't know what was going to
happen and we really had a good time
you're a wonderful uh wonderful host and
amanda terrific i had very little to do
with that amanda sarah making the goods
the great crew setting everything up you
know i was just trying to thank the crew
they get paid i'm surprised yet i'm
sorry but they get you know what i mean
i'm sick of this whole thing where we
thank the crew you know that's just
[ __ ] you know checks uh checks were
cashed you know
eduardo why should i thank you for
anything you're making a you're making
good money here yeah [ __ ] you eduardo
yeah what she said yeah i agree you can
turn off his mic if you eduardo did you
have a good time i had a great time we
did a lovely job and my hat's off to you
thank you i don't mean it because you
got a chat i cast a check already yeah i
cancelled the check you can have one you
can have my praise or the check which do
you want
the check
damn it who would ever choose your
praise instead because you can't even
pray no it's not your praise is followed
by
the [ __ ] that i love the idea of
i
[Laughter]
have a strict rule i will pay you or i
will praise you
but the praise is also a form of payment
so you get one or the other jesus i
would love
a maniac just trying to instill that at
work it'd just be so funny to me praise
or pay um well i have kids that need i
guess it's pay then huh
yeah
my daughter's in a private school then
it's pay is it
and [ __ ] you do your job
no praise from me
you're angry that they want to get paid
eduardo weren't you impressed with
gourley's home it's really nice
beautiful immaculate immaculate outdoor
vibe and the drinks were delicious
eduardo did you have any feeling at all
be honest because i know i did
any feeling in all of why does he get to
have such a nice home in such a nice
yard what just you know what i mean he's
a good guy and everything but it's
really spectacular
and you're a horrible person yes i know
so i mean because i'm a horrible person
that's the system that america has
i was rewarded for myself
you're saying i'm such a nice and good
person
exactly that's what i was going for oh
you know i will take praise there's no
hint of mendacity or cruelty with you
and yet you seem to be living as nicely
as i hear
and shredder
um you son of a [ __ ] yeah and you have
uh lots of nice touches sort of zen are
you still talking no zen you know zen
gardens he has he has a lot of nice
things in his yard did i it has a
beautiful pool too that i was
disappointed we didn't even get to use i
thought initially i think if we had one
more round to chill chunks
sure yeah for sure it ended up like
brian jones at the bottom of a pool
well i'm sorry
from the
who right no from the original maybe the
founding member of the rolling stones
ended up at the bottom of a pool keith
moon died i was thinking of him from the
who it's it's
why was he at the bottom of the pool he
died he drowned he oh and he may have
the coroner said he had had a chilled
chum
just before he went swimming i'm just
saying
a lot of conspiracy theories about the
loss of brian jones yeah you should come
over and drink a little and swim
wow well it's a bad combination
and that's why eduardo i think it was
wise did you have a chilled chum eduardo
uh i technically was working so i'm not
sure how i should answer this
how about answer it honestly and let me
be the judge of
just be trust that you're in a fair
environment and answer honestly i will
trust you i had one drink you're fired
get out it was delicious
i hope it was because you're losing this
job now i'm sorry i have to run a very
tight ship yeah you can have your job
back or you can have praise in fairness
do you want your job back or praise
which one do you want in mordo take my
damn it
all right you have your job back now
but that's it
no no of course what do you mean you're
not a surgeon
well we were podcasting so i
i couldn't have a drink for 36 hours
before or yeah you're not flying an
american airlines flight you're allowed
to i encourage people here to drink
before and after podcasting really and
during if necessary okay why don't we
have drinks here
well we know why you don't have a drink
here why i think that was periodic
surprise stuff yeah yeah i think we
should have drinks i just i had a great
time too i mean not that i normally
wouldn't have but more fun than i
normally have doing this this is fun and
all but that was real fun
you